previously on the Matt Walsh show wow
humans really have to pay money to stay
alive you want slavery that's what
you're asking for you want slaves I have
kids I'm a single mother okay why are
you a single mother that's another
question it's never asked
and now for part two so we're gonna
check out some uh tick tocks from some
lazy people basically lazy tick tocks
let's start with uh clip three put me
with the girls who want to be rich like
I'm tired of this like I want that black
girl luxury I want to wake up and do
anything I want I want to have my own
business I want to have my own YouTube I
want to have my own everything I don't
want to go to work I don't want to work
for nobody and it might sound so lazy
people be like what's your dream job I
no dream job I want to get up and
literally do what I want to do eat what
I want to eat why are we paying for
groceries why are we paying for food I
want to get up and take a vacation
whenever I want to take it I can't watch
this first of all my dad instincts like
none of these people had dads okay the
job of your dad is to say to you oh you
want to do all that stuff you want to
well you can't okay you can't
I want to do everything I want to do I
want to go on vacations I want to have a
business I want to be a millionaire I
want this I want that I see y'all look
at all those rich people in nice houses
I want one of those you can't have it
you can't it's not gonna happen Okay no
stop yelling at me
I say this to my kids all the time just
the other day my kids they got into
their minds they were to go to a water a
water park
randomly like on a Saturday at three
o'clock in the afternoon when we go to a
water park no but I want to go well I'm
not taking you good luck how you getting
there huh like going to water park sorry
but I want to Dad well we're not doing
it so you want to doesn't mean anything
these people they need someone in their
life they need someone in life who will
tell them that and they never had it and
it's ruined them they will be failures
they'll be miserable failures their
whole lives because they never had
anyone tell them no
dad is gone like the fact that you want
to do something doesn't mean anything
your desires don't mean anything that
has no pull has no weight
okay no one cares that you want to there
are a lot of things you want to do so
that doesn't matter the simple fact of
wanting doesn't matter you know why
because everyone else has things that
they want so why would they be focused
on what you want you're not focusing on
anybody what else wants you only think
about yourself I Want I Want I Want Me
Be Me Mine Mine Mine Mine you think
anyone else is operating any differently
really at the end of the day if you want
something go out and get it go out and
work for it if you really want it you
know a company's looking out for you
when they actually upgrade your service
and they don't charge you for it pure
talk just added data to every new and
existing plan they're also including a
mobile hotspot with each new plan as
well with no price increase whatsoever
if you've considered pure talk before
but you haven't made the switch you need
to take a look again for just twenty
dollars a month you'll get unlimited
talk text and now 50 more 5G data plus a
mobile hotspot I love pure talk not only
do they offer great services but they
also happen to be veteran owned and they
only hire the best United States based
customer service team available remember
you vote with how you spend your money
so stop supporting woke wireless
companies that don't support you when
you go to puretalk.com Walsh you'll save
an additional 50 off your first month
because they actually value you that's
puretalk.com
Wireless for Americans by Americans okay
just play the next one
thanks walking
I hate it I hate it I hate it I hate it
I hate it there are men on this app
putting on crusty wigs pretending to be
women making bands and vans and bands
and bears of money and I have to clock
in clock in clock in
I want to do absolutely freaking nothing
how to make money
I don't wanna clap in no no no no no no
no
it was you
okay
turn it off turn it off speaking of uh
not having fathers well I mean he had he
had me for a moment on there are men
pretending to be women bit so I I you
know he won
there's a moment of like okay I can
respect this guy but then but then that
all dissipated pretty quickly I struggle
so much with this because I can't even
relate
to the desire to do nothing I don't have
that in me really you want to do nothing
what kind of life is that really you
want to spend every day
not doing anything that to me sounds
like a nightmare you're in hell and
that's just not an improvement if you
want something in life you can actually
have it if you're willing to work and
here's the thing so this is where this
is where the the American dream is still
is still is still alive I believe it is
barely and the reason I say that is this
if you
are actually willing to work harder than
almost everybody else if you really are
willing to put in the time and part of
working hard is also developing skills
which is which which you will kind of
naturally do as you're working hard and
if you'll do that like you will be
successful whatever you consider look at
anyone around you who you would consider
successful
and and and what you're going to find is
there's a Common Thread
that ties almost all them together which
is that they work harder than you they
just do so while you're whining because
you have to work one hour past your nine
to five deadline
they're working 13 hours and not
complaining about it like that's what it
takes and if you're not willing to do
that fine nobody's gonna Force you
you'll live a mediocre life
and you won't have all the things you
want and that's it
you could be a loser you can be a loser
just don't complain about it that's all
I'm asking
yeah
I wanna do absolutely freaking nothing
and make money